[Music]
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about the olympics
and i love thinking talking about sports
and the physics of sports
and however good i am at that charles
lou is better and that's why we've got
charles liu
on the show charles always good to have
you oh pleasure thank you so much
just thanks over all these years for
being such a good friend of star talk
because when
it has been my pleasure when the going
gets tough we call charles
all right and it is my pleasure and i
don't think you did any professional
sports we have gary who
gives us street cred here uh street cred
gary
and yeah we only i only just learned in
this episode the man threw the javelin
and the discus so go for gary there
all right and and and uh chuck
chuck nice what what sports have you
done with it um
well uh there's um there's something
called the dignity throw
[Applause]
so as many people know i wrestled i i
wrestled in high school i was captain of
the team and undefeated
wrestled in college a little bit of
graduate school but when i got to
college
after an undefeated record in high
school it was like a whole other
whole nother another because i started
wrestling
people who would like these are like
farm boys okay
from the midwest that's all there you go
that's it that's right i don't know like
what what they've been carrying with
logs around the cabin
you know whatever is the stereotype of
the farm boy
that's who i was wrestling so these
these are regions of the country that
have
where wrestling is very serious they
fill arenas
and so i was delighted to
not be the best because when you're the
best
what is your how do you learn what do
you do and so
so i had a losing record for most of my
time in college but that didn't matter
it was my favorite sport then and it
continues to be
so so and that was intercollegiate uh
wrestling obviously not professional
wrestling
okay and uh international rules are a
little more strict than what we do just
uh intercollegiate here in the united
states and in the olympics there's
freestyle and greco-roman so that's what
that's what we have going on
what is freestyle well so uh
it's easier to know what freestyle is
once i tell you what greco-roman is
so greco-roman wrestling is just your
upper body
so you can't sweep the leg no you can't
do that
[Laughter]
you can't you can't use your leg
for anything it is just your upper body
strength your arms
you know your and and the rest so you
they you you have people who tend to be
very good at body throws
right you try to get a grip of their
upper torso and your maneuvering for
position
and and ideally you'll execute a body
throw where the throw
includes getting their back to the mat
and then it's one
smooth motion and so those guys tend to
have
spindly legs and huge torsos
but what is what is a passivity point
in greco-roman oh oh yeah so what
happened and i don't know when that came
in
but what happened was that in both
freestyle and in in greco-roman
they started putting in rules to speed
up the game
okay and to force you to always be
attacking and
and because you used to sort of jockey
for position
and feel the person out and minutes
would go by and nothing would happen
all right and so since olympics still
they have to make money with their tv
rights
i don't know if money did it or just the
fan interest or whatever
but they started caught it started
costing you
if you were not perceived by the referee
as always trying to be an aggressor
and if you're always just being the
receiving end and not the delivering end
that can cost you
on both sides okay and so i mean sorry
both
branches of the sport so that sped up
the game
in fact there's and i forgot the exact
conditions under which this is true
but if you are tied at the end in points
because you get points on a takedown and
if your back is exposed to the mat there
are various ways you earn points if
you're tied
they will start the next round
with each of you already being granted a
grip
around the other person's torso
you already have a grip around them this
is like that new rule in baseball where
in extra innings they start
the inning with a runner on second base
okay
wow did you did you know about this it's
a new rule i know this it's called the
ghost
runner it's called the ghost runner all
right and so
they start off the inning yeah you get a
free base runner on second base and you
know who that runner is is the person
made the last out
in the previous inning okay so
the last at-bat person right so so it's
an attempt to speed the game up
and and to to put more action in the
sport
so neil is there an ultimate wrestling
move i mean so
if we're watching the olympics and the
wrestling comes on we've got to be
thinking
do this and then we can all shout at the
tv yeah yeah
i would say before you answer that
question before you answer that question
neil
uh i recall you telling me some years
ago
about a move that you did in high school
which was
essentially undefeatable there was no
defense against it it was like the crane
technique in the karate kit
so maybe that you want to bring that up
with the
karate kid i just remember you telling
me this this method
where you were able to immobilize your
opponents against which they had no
defense
oh wow uh i'm trying to remember what
that might have been because i had a i
had a few moves where if i can get
that grip then that that's the end if
it so the challenge is can you execute
the grip
before you then complete the move
because the grip
immobilizes your opponent in such a way
now you can do with them what you wish
and if you're if you're quick enough and
you get them slightly off balance you
take them to the mat and
the takedown move is is included
the pin is part of the takedown move and
so but
i can tell you this people are very
nimble and they're very strong and
they're very
so you don't tend to see that but here's
a move
where if you see it executed basically
the the match is going to be over within
five seconds
okay and it's called the cradle i'd have
to say if i were voting
i'd be curious what fellow wrestlers if
they had a different vote on this
uh from what i'm telling you here the
cradle
is where one of my arms raps you're
facing me
you're perpendicular to me on the mat
one of my arms is
under your head like i'm just cradling
you like you're cradling a baby
right my other arm
goes under the knee of either one of
your legs
it doesn't matter it won't matter and so
now
you're i bring that knee up to your
chin and then lock my arms
okay so now now i
have you i'm sorry there's what are you
gonna do
where are you gonna what are you wait
where are you gonna go
and once i have that if i can get that
in any way
i just have to roll back over roll back
and you i'll roll your shoulder blades
down to the mat
and then the referee's there watching it
and then i love this sound where they
they slam that i'll do it on the table
here there it is they slam and that's
and that's it and if you watch someone
get into a cradle that generally they're
not coming out of it
and that's the end of the match so you
you just watch for that move
wow it's it's almost once once it's
once you have the grip it's you can't
it's kind of over now you can try to
kick out of it
okay you can try to kick um so you bring
one other foot
to to to scissor lock your two ankles
and just try to kick out of it but if
i'm no consider
just just see what how how
how many muscles are involved in this my
entire
chest okay my deltoids my
biceps all of my upper body strength
is now has you enclosed in this cradle
move
so it is one of the most effective
invocations of muscle strength of any
move there is
and do you do you do your trash talk at
that point when you got him in the
mean you pretty much know that it's over
i mean you just go
how do you like that you little baby i
got you
yeah daddy's home your little baby
huh where's your
this is the olympics this is not the
world wrestling
federation that's a different dynamic
right charles you think that's going to
stop chuck
i mean you take the cradle bring them up
a little bit and then
do the atomic knee drop see not there
or the back breaking whatever that's a
different sport i think i'll call that
uh but the cradle is um so there if you
can get someone
in a cradle where you're not already
down on the mat
you know if you're just sort of locking
up and you're you're twisting and
turning
you can i can get you in a cradle even
though it looks like my back is towards
the mat
and all i have to do is just keep
rotating around and you you can't stand
you there's nothing you can do and your
hands are just useless at that point
you can try to push me away but you've
got no leverage you've got nothing
and by the way i haven't checked this
year but
women's wrestling is rapidly growing in
popularity in the united states
and you know this is such a sort of a
male masculine testosterone thing that i
was
initially skeptical i say we really is
this going to work and then i watch some
matches like oh my gosh
bring it on bring it on and so wonderful
it was it was really it was delighted to
see it and another
very important thing about wrestling and
now that it's you know
it's got uh can i say this both genders
right
yeah it's got the full gender spectrum
is represented
the the what's true also about
wrestling is that it's you do it in
different way categories
right so no matter your weight there's a
category you can compete in and it's not
well i was never
tall enough to do this and i'm not
strong enough to do that that
in wrestling you are matched up pound
for pound yeah and that actually is a
point
at least perfectly the question i have
for you neil about that and that is
how much weight makes a difference
in other words the weight classes if
you're like at the bottom of a weight
class
compared to the top of the no you always
be you always want the top of the weight
class
you want the top of the weight class at
all times right like what is the
difference i mean one of these days i'll
tell you about uh
the one time that i had glory on the
wrestling mat
back in high school and but that's a
different story i
i was underweight the other guy by at
least
25 pounds and and i still wipe the floor
with him
uh but but the question be that the
question becomes
wait that's charlie that's the first
time i've ever heard you use the phrase
i wipe the floor
with him this is like the last sentence
i ever thought would have come out of
your mouth
we're obviously a bad influence on
charles i didn't taunt the dude but
it's true um but that's a story for
another time but my point is
like at what like how much does it
matter can
an excellent technique defeat a heavier
opponent
it's not likely here's my point um
if you weigh less you can defeat someone
heavier than you if there's
if they're not as good a wrestler but if
they're just as good as
a wrestler as you you will simply lose
wow
here's my point you generally as you get
bigger you get slower
okay one advantage i had was i was i had
very fast reflexes
and have very long arms so i would use
moves that would exploit
those two facts okay um but
i was always taller than my opponent all
right
and but with exactly the same weight
well if we if we are the same weight and
i'm taller and neither of us have body
fat
my opponent is stronger than i am that
is that is the definition of muscle
strength okay
the cross-sectional area of your muscle
directly correlates
with your strength so if you are shorter
your muscles are bigger than mine
because we weigh the same
i have to know that in advance to
maneuver around their strong points
to do things that might be quicker than
they are or overreach
or be able to reach farther than they
can so that's an important fact
so i would claim charles that the person
was 25 pounds heavier than you
was simply not as talented as you
because if he
if he were he'd be stronger than you
in every way and have all of your moves
and there'd be nothing you could do on
them
guys that's all i'm saying and if you
want someone smaller to
kick someone they'll execute some
different kind of
rules that are not the rules that the
heavier person
is is a participant then so if you're
good at like taekwondo and you can
and you half the weight of the other
person you go kick him in the throat
okay yeah that's a david and goliath
scenario
right but i bet you if goliath had a
sling
the way david had a sling goliath would
have
taken out david okay so
we're not talking about lightweight
talent versus
heavyweight no talent here we're talking
about everybody with talent
okay so so weight is the defining
difference
given equal talent given equal that's
why you got to match up the weights
it's a little bit of what the wrestling
universe is all about
i'm delighted to help bring that to you
neil degrasse tyson here as always
keep looking up